mais sens de la télévision en troisième
chaîne première fois
[Musique]
voilà à ce que c'est la troisième chaîne
juste avant la troisième c'est peu de
choses finalement peut même dire que
c'est rien du tout rien du tout rien que
les ondes de monsieur rc de monsieur
maxwell qui courent dans tous les sens
demandent les voit pas ça ne vous fait
pas froid dans le dos et 3e chaîne
privée de 3ème chaîne
si bien sûr remarqué c'est peut-être le
moment le plus exaltant de son histoire
commence à une déception que l'info papa
de critiques par londres le
téléspectateur courroucé noter que ce
téléspectateur là serait ingrat parce
que en janvier il a versé pour deux
chaînes et on lui en donne une troisième
avant la fin de l'année pour l'instant
c'est le paradis c'est la béatitude
oui dit on va pas rester dans la
béatitude désertique jusqu'à demain on
en voudrait raison et je crois qu'il est
temps de meubler ce froid décor mur
apprentis sorciers dit d'organes
je vais essayer sol t'amusant un pote ça
va mieux on sent vraiment chez soi oui
oh rien ne manque
indispensable ou là bas qu'est ce que
c'est que ce poisson rouge
ah ça c'est pour les interludes pour les
interviewer syndic est sûrement et au 15
août
on est vraiment sur une chaîne de télé
oui mais il ya quelque chose qui me
tient qu'à huit mois les téléspectateurs
qui viennent d'ouvrir leur poste à
l'instant même
ils savent pas ce qu'ils sont en train
de voir c'est vrai il n'a peut-être
qu'ils s'imaginent qu'ils sont sur la
première sur la deuxième chaîne
quelle horreur si on faisait un petit
billet dès l'ouverture les raisons on ne
fait jamais trop bien les choses
meilleures cibles mais sens de la
troisième chaîne de télévision deuxième
fois
[Musique]
mais
vous ne trouvez pas quand même que
jusqu'à présent cette troisième chaîne
ressemble terriblement aux deux
premières je crois que vous avez raison
il manque deux choses le champagne est
la marraine nec mois à la marraine mais
non c'est la marraine la plus importante
voyons très bien alors comment vous la
voyez vous la marraine de la troisième
chaîne la marraine de la troisième
chaîne
moi je sais pas je la vois charmante pis
quand je la vois c'est pas ça du tout
c'est pas ça du tout tv peut pas du tout
bon alors je recommence c'est mieux non
et mieux c'est déjà vu sur les deux
autres chaînes mais ah bon ouais bon
alors je me concentrais sinon moi vous
mais metz et anne marie david oui c'est
la marraine de la troisième chaîne oui
bonsoir anne marie david marine de la
troisième says bonsoir à tous et si ado
à porter ou à votre filleul une chanson
qui naîtra ce soir comme la troisième
chaîne alors qu'est ce que vous en
pensez ma marraine
je vais vous dire je n'aurais pas mieux
fait moi même
[Musique]
c'est
2 et quand même
qu'ont-elles
c'est quand même hein
on est mieux
le
en ouvrant les
on entend
[Musique]
là
oui
mais [ __ ]
[Musique]
choléra
au saut
on va voir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on oublie le
m
on se
[Musique]
hu
[Applaudissements]
ce
je
[Musique]
c'est quand même à deux ados
tu sais quand même
on est bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
j'ai le froid
[Musique]
il est trop tard
on est trois
[Musique]
et
lorsque vient
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
selon
c'est un
[Musique]
qualité
je tape
germa rennes voulez-vous baptisé
officiellement notre troisième show
commence là et bien c'est très simple
en vous saisissant de cette bouteille de
champagne très bonne marque d'ailleurs
et en la brisant sur cette niche
symbolique que va-t-il se passer après
il se passera qu'une autre chaîne qui
vient de naître sera baptisé
officiellement troisième du nom voilà
tout est prêt derrière vous êtes sûr tu
réellement tout après quelques questions
c'est toujours la même chose alors la
balle est maintenant vous avez vu ma
bosse il n'y a pas de doute la troisième
scène ça va être un bon sixième le
directeur est ce facile à attraper
excuses à monsieur le général général on
ne se le directeur général par hassen
général de directeur non c'est un
directeur général et qu'elle est
différente mais la différence c'est
qu'en général on dirait directeur
général on dimanche de leurs directeurs
et sous-directeurs est en général et en
civil
hassen général en civil non à directeur
général n'est pas un militaire alors
pourquoi dites vous quand guy en général
puisqu'il est facile j'ai dit en général
comme je l'aï dit en particulier les
particuliers le directeur non je viens
pas reculer comme on dit en général
quand on me dira couramment f1
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on dit messieurs
les directeurs généraux pourquoi
assiste-t-on deux et ça se fait
couramment général écouteurs fois toute
façon directeur ou général ce qu'ils ont
dit et bien dit c'est aussi parce que
moi qui suis balayeur si j'avais à faire
un discours de mes directeurs je ne sais
pas si je serai trouver mes mots mais si
voyons mais non mais non
oui je suis pas jaloux chacun sa
spécialité et je vais vous dire une
chose peut-être après tout monsieur
compte au coin du balayage n'y entend
rien du tout et puis autre chose on peut
être tranquille ce sont les petits comme
vous et moi qui la tenons la troisième
chaîne on au messie mais s'il tenait moi
qui tiens ce ballet si je me mets à
balayer les ondes et la chaîne qu'est ce
qui reste un abbaoui mais ça c'est parce
qu'on est machiniste
mais si on était musicien on l'a tiendra
la troisième chaîne pareil
vous ne pouvez pas non je pense à la
musique ne vous dérange pas un ange dans
prix à quoi pensez-vous
je pense que j'ai pas envie de jouer
pourquoi parce que je suis là d'être un
obscur et alors alors tout à l'heure au
moment du solo de violon on va voir voir
quoi on va voir qu'on n'entendra rien
alors je suis désolé de vous décevoir
mais dans seulement morceaux il n'y a
pas de solo de violon non mes gains sur
le trombone et quel rapport y at il
entre un solo de trombone et violon vous
avez sur les genoux est bien là que ce
violon mais été prêté par le type que
vous voyez là bas avec mon trombone et
alors alors tout à l'heure au moment du
sol au trombone il sera pas s'en servir
mais evp pourquoi il joue du violon non
il joue de la clarinette
alors à qui appartient ce violon au type
qui joue de la basse a alors si je
comprends bien ce type qui joue de la
basse est un violoniste qui a prêté son
violon au clarinettiste à qui vous avez
donné votre trouble dans les chances du
violon est à peu près ça sauf que le
type qui joue d'abbas ne joue pas de
violons mais enfin pourquoi tous ces
échanges un soir d'inauguration pour
démontrer que c'est nous les musiciens
qui tenons la troisième chaîne ouais
d'accord souhaité musiciens mais si on
intègre danseurs le tiendra la troisième
chaîne pareil bord marcel on a travaillé
tournée libération même es3 ya pas mais
m qui tiennent ce soir c'est une
libération de la troisième chaîne faut
pas rater pour la libération mais voyons
m vous parlez comme si j'étais un grand
mauvais sujet mais non c'est ce que
c'est pour prouver qu'ils sont les
grosseurs l'intérêt sera encore sous
forme de radio aller 1 2 6 12
il est bien mon gros sujet on n'a jamais
vu ça sur les deux autres chaînes je dis
ça je dis ouais d'accord si on était
danseur mais si on était pompier est
pareil
et vous j'aime bien leur métier vous
parce que je viens de dire quoi vous
êtes sourd
qu'est ce que vous avez dit vous êtes
sous nom qu'est ce que j'avais dit avant
de dire je des sous j'aime bien votre
métier vous c'est ce que je vous ai dit
vous êtes sourd pourquoi pourquoi vous
êtes sourd non pourquoi vous aimez bien
autre métier parce que c'est un métier
noble ça c'est vrai nous sommes pompiers
de service est un métier dans lequel on
vit sur une grande échelle ait alors
question chauffage favorite je vais vous
dire on est indispensable la télévision
même sur la troisième chaîne même pas
aux questions sur la présence de monter
jeanne au bûcher par exemple la danse du
feu la mère de madame les femmes
savantes en un mot sans nous pas de
spectacle fut mon exact il a eu du feu
je crois que vous suiviez +11 et moi je
suis tout feu tout flamme
si on était cameramen pareil pourquoi
êtes-vous devenu caméraman parce que à
l'école j'étais sage comme une image
moi c'est toujours
l'objectif à ulysse a été bercée par le
son des sirènes moi j'ai été bercé par
sont des caméras puis d'origine nantaise
alors le gros plan ça me connaît moi par
contre est en entente et militariste
joel le plan général et bien je ressens
caméraman pas de caméra et sans caméra
pente télé et pas de téléphone de
troisième chaîne et qui dit tu remportes
troisième chaîne d'une pas de deuxième
deux premières voilà bref on nous
prépare la soirée si on était pour la
soirée bien il y aurait pas de four
inaugural voilà et bien maintenant
silence on tourne
et si on était preneur de son pareil
indispensable qu'on serait on
atteindrait comme ça la troisième chaîne
dans le fond quand j'ai pensé nous
qu'ils en sont la troisième chaîne
commence à nous parce que s'ils avaient
pas preneurs de sons pourrait pas
reprendre en quoi le sont mais il y en
avait pas pas de quoi pas de son eh ben
on reviendrait au temps du cinéma muet à
8 mètres noyés par télévisions et pas de
preneur de son oui billets mais l'image
oui mais alors une image chanson c'est
comme un marin son bateau comme un
trapéziste entre aps comme un esquimau
sans entracte
un pain sans farine and de quoi faire
une deux sont étudiants ont une image
trouvée dans une autre d'un pêcheur son
poisson à voilà ça c'est une belle image
tenez prenez sa prof est gentil mais
c'est une belle image grâce à vous au
foie gras savoir ce qui vous a tendu la
perche et si on était
vous êtes fous vous allez nous faire
virer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'équipe
pour
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
enfin
m
e
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
non
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que vous regardez là je
regarde l'album de photographies que je
me suis fait pour me souvenir de cette
journée pendant toute ma vie vous avez
beaucoup de photos 2 2 mais c'est
monsieur guillaume directeur de la
troisième chaîne en train de pousser son
landau voyez là c'est mignon c'est là au
monsieur arthur commente avec ses trois
filles
pour les deux premières sont déjà grands
d'un troisième est très mignonne vous
croyez qu'ils la drogue et arrive au
chemin de fer sais pas j'espère en tout
cas dans la vie un troisième enfant
c'est très important
oui surtout quand ils ont eu deux
auparavant enfin pour tourner une
troisième fallait bien qu'ils en aient
eu deux auparavant ça sera la première
régie et pour une 2e ce soir on fait
très bon la troisième est d'ailleurs
tout ce qui est roi et importe exact le
3 est un chiffre sacré mais regardez
vous avez les sept péchés capitaux les
sept plaies d'égypte en anglais pourquoi
citer vous le chiffre 7 pour nous parler
du 3 parce que comme le 12 le 3 et 7
sont des nombres sacré exact ce sont des
nombreux sacré qui selon les jeunes
chimistes et ré théosophes codifie
l'harmonie universelle et que l'on
retrouve le plus souvent dans
l'énumération importante et comme les
douze apôtres par exemple les douze
coups de minuit la chanson bien connue
j'ai fait ça en 12 savez vous quelle est
la définition du 3 dans le dictionnaire
en sept volumes
ouais c'est un plus de noms de plus un
alors si je comprends bien les deux
premières chaînes de télévision n'ont
été créés que pour faire patienter les
futurs téléspectateurs de la troisième
nous n'irons pas jusque là jusqu'au
japon c'est que vous venez de dire
mais néanmoins il est à remarquer que
depuis la naissance du monde le 3 a
toujours été présent d'une façon
remarquable les exemples d exhaure oui
mais bel et bien sûr bien sûr j'ai un
fan
vous avez par exemple la règle de 3 à le
5 à 7 non je pense que le provient à
faire dans le sens car si le 3 et celui
qui vient troubler le 5 à 7 des deux oui
c est alors dans l'histoire on rencontre
très très souvent le chiffre 3 par
exemple les trois fils de noé
les trois rois mages les trois évêchés
etes vous les mères d'un no messe tous
les vers d'un oui après je les avais
dans le désordre ou le tiercé
on en parle d'histoire va votre cheville
et cheval de troie qu'est ce que ça fait
de l'histoire alors voyez bon je
continue en littérature vous avez les
trois mousquetaires étaient quatre mais
trois plus un riff angiographie en
savoie les trois vallées au canada les
trois rivières les trois épis dans les
volets 38 grata au nom donc preuves au
cinéma le troisième homme
les trois lanciers du bengale les 39
marches à l'eau en 39 c pa 3 ha
attention dans 39 il ya 3 et 9 qui est
un multiple de 3 puisque trois fois
trois fonds 9
alors d'un côté vous avez 3 à 3 et 1 3
qui précède ce qui fait 4 à 3 et 4 x 3
12 comme les douze mois de l'année
exacte mais revenons aux chiffres 3 oui
alors en mari nous avons 2 3 m'a mis en
vrac les trois orfèvres les trois valses
le visionner les trois dimensions les
trois pyramides
il est trois sergents de la rochelle
qu'en quatrième était en terme oui et en
ce qui concerne les personnages
historiques marquée par le chiffre 3 ils
sont dans la légion
ouais ils sont dans la région 1 ils ont
beaucoup à wissant beaucoup richard iii
napoléon iii oui duguay 3-1 au quattro
et pas trois trous trois trous ou jouer
au golf
non je parle de duguay-trouin mais quel
rapport entre duguay-trouin chiffre 3
bon on enchaîne alexandre iii faut qu'on
enchaîne alexandre iii mais non le site
1 qu'est ce qu'il a fait par le pont oui
oui alors comptez pas vous avez paul iii
qui a fait pas mal de choses rires au
moins trois puits pi3 qui n'a rien fait
du tout et terminaux en citant tiers
ministre à l'esprit est moi
[Musique]